[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
eric hanson has covered notre dame since
the mid 90s 1997 and uh he covers notre
dame football for the south bend tribune
where's this rank on shocking days
at notre dame and notre dame history
there eric
shocking days of my career i've been
doing this since 1983 and
that was number one i mean i
just didn't see it coming and i'm still
kind of shaking my head brian kelly just
finished building a new house near
campus
and um oh boy
it was uh it's just
you know and as much as he's
his whole identity has been tied into
notre dame winning a national
championship and him fighting to
put notre dame
in a position to make that a reality
and ruffling some feathers along the way
it's just an interesting left turn for
me from my perspective
how would you sum up the last 24 hours
and do you think all of this happened in
a 24-hour period
i do i i i think that
brian was
you know was always willing to listen to
people
but i don't think he thought saw himself
as walking away from notre dame
and
you know i think it just all kind of
came together i mean his own assistant
coaches didn't know you know
and and so
uh you know jack swordberg mentioned
that you know he
had conversations with brian
last night that's when they first talked
about it
so
um
you know
the the thing about it is brian did
leave the program in a good place and
whoever walks in the door next is gonna
have a much easier job than brian did
walking in the door in december of
2009
why did he leave
you know i was talking to a friend of
his just before we got on the air here
and
you know i think
the money had something to do with it
but i just think
you know maybe a different challenge
maybe he just
got tired of
trying to fight the same fights and uh
um
just thought well let's let's try to do
this somewhere else
it's surprises again
we're still kind of walking through the
shock
of his own friends of his own inner
circle
that this happened and so it just
i wish i had a better answer for you dan
um
well you sound like somebody who is
shocked
i am i'm just
i'm shaking my head at 60 years old you
know two to go and and brian's a young
60 he takes care of himself he does yoga
he he has a lot of balance in his life i
mean
you know he was the oldest coach to ever
coach at notre dame he's the first one
to be 60 years old to be on that
sideline so he's doing something right
but
you know
his whole identity was tied in
recruiting and everything else was tied
into his belief when nobody else was
believing him that notre dame could win
a national championship
and and all the battles that he had to
fight for the jumbotron and facilities
and artificial turf that just made the
traditionalists mad
you know
that was all who brian kelly was and
that's why you know right last night i
wrote he kind of broke the promise to
himself
that he could do this that he could pull
it off all right so the short list of
candidates to replace him
you know the two that are the most
intriguing to me is luke fickle who's
the head coach at cincinnati and
who has
no interest in being distracted from
what they're trying to do this weekend
with houston so i would be shocked if
any there was any movement this week
with him
and then i think marcus freeman's
intriguing i think it's a risk only from
the standpoint
that
non-head coaches non-head college
coaches
haven't done well in this job
and
uh no matter how talented they seem kind
of coming in
and marcus has only been at
notre dame for a year boy is he a sharp
guy when you talk to him the defensive
coordinator the defensive coordinator he
can recruit
um he he handles having six kids pretty
well
so he's he's a good multitasker
but i think he's an intriguing pick i
think it would be a risk i think that is
the
guy that the players are building
support for i'm not sure how much of a
voice they'll have in this but that's
kind of who they're kind of pushing
uh notre dame to look at and i think he
will get along i wonder about this eric
we're talking to eric hanson he covers
notre dame football for the south bend
tribune let's say this is
i don't know eight months ago a year ago
urban myers on the fox pregame show set
and you have openings
including jacksonville but you have
notre dame as an opening and urban
famously when he was leaving utah i
think did a pit stop at notre dame and
then didn't like what he heard and then
kept going south to florida
but
urban meyer on the radar here at all
with notre dame
i think
the circumstances that led him to leave
ohio state
would be a tough sell for the notre dame
trustees
as much as they'd love to have him as
much as that was kind of always the
dream coach
i i think that would keep notre dame
from
moving on that even if there were
interested interest from urban on the
other side of that
what's a better opening usc
lsu notre dame
i'd throw oklahoma in there but oklahoma
i mean if you want to but
best job out of those four
i think notre dame is a great
job
i i think it's the hardest job of the
four yeah
um you know oklahoma you have texas
sitting there
usc you have california recruiting
louisiana per capita has great talent
and notre dame you know where notre
dame's biggest draw has been for talent
in the last four years california
and number two is georgia it's not ohio
or indiana or illinois i mean they're
going all over the place
and i think that's and now brian kelly's
raised the bar on expectations i think
it's the most difficult of those jobs
what would be the best job
i would say probably usc just because
they have the tradition the recruiting
and everything
all rolled into one and i think they can
stop
those california stars from being so
transient i mean you look at ohio state
they're quarterbacks from california
alabama their quarterbacks from
california
uh what are you gonna do they're
quarterbacks from california what are
you gonna do the rest of the day eric
i got a lot of writing to do the rest of
the day i'm gonna write a column on what
the next steps should look like and uh
then we have the beautiful college
football playoff show tonight wouldn't
that be wild if
all the tumblers fell and notre dame
somehow backed into the playoff picture
well if if somebody slips up here in
these conference title games if alabama
loses notre dame may may slip in there
and then
who's coaching notre dame in the bowl
game
well they are not gonna or they're not
gonna have an interim coach right now i
think they would appoint one at that
point but again you're gonna have a tug
of war with brian kelly wanting to pull
some people to lsu oh i know i know
it may be you and me coaching notre dame
in the bowl game
well oklahoma's bringing back bob stoops
can notre dame bring back uh lou holtz
or
rudy how about rudy coaches him
uh then i'm leaving the beat
i'd rather see somebody from the media
coach
eric thanks for joining us know you got
a busy day we appreciate your time
thank you for having me on that's eric
hanson it covers notre dame and it
covers them for the south bend tribune